uh fascinated me with your Twitter page
and you like first of all how you are a
doctor right well I'm a PhD I can't save
anybody's life perform you know
Victorian surgery amputation or
something anybody can right yeah is that
a real one this is this is a prop this
was a was a real fun thing to get
through customs when I was coming in
from Britain it's a Victorian amputation
saw it's called the Clockwork saw and
for people who are just listening it's
it's a circular saw and there would have
been a crank that you wound it with and
then you'd release it and it would spin
sort of automatically oh yeah and the
idea was that it would make it faster
but the reason why I love this saw so
much is that it was a massive failure
and um I don't think we talked about
failure enough in science and medicine
you know all the things that work
there's a lot of things that don't work
and so this guy who invented this saw
when he tried it out it was spinning so
fast that he took off his assistants
fingers oh Jesus Christ
heaven oops it never got out of
prototype phase so I had to recreate it
for my youtube channel
now when you in those old days when they
didn't have antibiotics and antiseptic
and right yeah when they saw someone's
leg off or something like that how many
times those people live well you could
pull through the operation that was one
part of it but then of course you could
die a post-operative infection yeah so
my book the butchering art really
focuses on this one guy named Joseph
Lister who applies germ theory and
develops antisepsis so germ fighting
techniques and most people don't know
who is but they know the product
Listerine mm-hm
so Wistrom was named after him but I I
always tell people that so basically a
Lister was a British surgeon and he came
to America in 1876 to convince the
medical community of germs and there was
a guy in the audience and he decided to
create this product Listerine but it
wasn't even a mouthwash in the
nineteenth century it was used to treat
gonorrhea whoa so but also I don't
endorse that dr. Mann
the comments already on the YouTube you
know she told me throw with story night
no III I don't endorse that and I'm sure
the Listerine company is not too pleased
I'm talking about that either
so Listerine now just is for breath
right yeah yeah that's all it does yeah
it's it's it's an antiseptic mouthwash
it's something any good for you
like is it good to kill all that stuff
inside your mouth like right but you're
a medical historian I would say that
Dennis would say that that Listerine is
still a good product
Metiria yeah like that I just use
something I wash something I got to
switch to wizardry now Joseph Lister so
how did he know how did he know that
there was berms that they were real so
let me let me take you back to you sort
of before he walks on the scene so these
operating theaters they were filled to
the rafters with ticketed spectators
people actually bought tickets to see
someone get their leg hacked off oh I
you know what no one's asked me that I
don't know how much it take it would
cost for that spectacle now I really
need to look into that what they pay to
watch now right you know we could say
you know and when I sent you my book I I
signed it and I said I thought that
being strapped to the Victorian
operating theatre was the original fear
factor because I can't imagine anything
worse than being strapped this table
yeah and so we're talking about before
anesthesia so you're fully awake and one
of my favorite surgeons is this guy
named Robert Liston he's 6 - he's really
tall for the 19th century and he could
hold you down with his left arm and he
could take your leg off in about 30
seconds oh Jesus which is what you'd
want that's what you'd want good but
that's still a long time it is yeah I
mean if we just sat here for 30 seconds
with dead air time and you could think
about you know hacking through that lag
just scream I wonder how many people
would be at the end of this podcast like
five people would be still on there
listening so so he was incredibly fast
he was known as the fastest knife in the
West End he was walking he was a showman
so he'd walk in and he'd say timey
gentleman and you could just hear the
ripple of pocket watch is there is there
is
yep there he is um and he's using a
knife in that photo yeah so actually the
Liston knife that he invented was this
long bladed knife which they think Jack
the Ripper may have also used which is
why those rumors are that Jack the
Ripper may have been a medical
practitioner but that was a really
common thought right yeah I mean we're
never gonna know who is right it's
unknowable we're we're still kind of
obsessed with this I've heard so many
different versions of that yeah and
recently there was some kind of bogus
DNA test of a shawl that they said
belonged to one of the victims but it's
impossible that's to prove the
provenance of the object but that was
that was Liston so he's 6 - he's really
tall one of my favorite stories is he
would go so fast as he was switching
instruments he'd hold these bloody
instruments in his mouth just like how
different this was that's the face I
wanted I want to be just totally
disgusted through this whole segment on
and as he was switching instruments he
accidentally caught cut off his
assistants finger and then as he was
switching instrument he slashed the code
of a spectator and the assistant died of
gangrene the patient died of gangrene
and the spectator died of fright so it's
just right
he just abrade blood Wow he got slashed
in the with the jacket and I guess he
had a heart attack from the stress and
so it's jokingly referred to as the only
operation with a 300 percent mortality
rate he did a good job that day he
killed three three people in one would
you say slashed you mean he cut the
spectator or just no he just cut their
code it was kind of switching
instruments all it took to kill someone
I thought people were tougher back then
well not that guy no he lives forever in
the butchery and art is bad guy had a
heart attack he must have had a heart
attack it said he died afraid maybe that
wasn't real maybe it was that course
shit doesn't it
stories you know they get blown out of
proportion yeah it just seems like did
you cut someone's jacket and they're
going to die well it's you know it's a
stressful situation people are getting
their limbs hacked off you know your
blood pressure would be really high um I
get it and these feeders were
I mean the the floor of the operating
theater was crowded as well so they'd
have to actually clear the floor
sometime so you can imagine you know
you're strapped to this and the leg
wasn't the worst thing so one of the
tweets that you shared of mine which
your platforms seem to enjoy quite a lot
and sold me a lot of books by the way I
thank you I'm was this story about this
guy who was suffering from a bladder
stone and it got stuck in his Aretha and
so out of desperation he stuck a nail
down his penis and he hammered it to
break it up yeah yeah and yeah people
would sign your platform for that story
so they they obviously are ready for
this interval how did that work again
that didn't work right it did not work
no he died you know whoops that guy
definitely died um but it's it really
illustrates how desperate people were
back then and how few options you know
they had there's the image of it I don't
think you'll have to show this on
YouTube Jamie on YouTube
really that's clearly a penis there's
penises and breasts on Jamie a lot of
you think they look at this more
carefully
all right it's not on if people want to
see it will tweet Twitter is the most
open of all platforms I'll let you get
away with almost everything you can have
porn on Twitter yeah well I mean I don't
have any problems with Instagram I put
that stuff up but yeah but maybe some
things get removed from Instagram it's
really kind of interested it seems to be
dependent upon how many people complain
yeah probably
there's there's always those people out
there looking to be offended I just
think they just want to do something
just want to press that button yeah
there we go
yeah I know I get you know at this point
there's so many objects that that can
cause offense of course with medical
history and it's it's you know there's a
lot of dark history body-snatchers and
things like that and I'm a firm believer
that we should tell these stories openly
because they happened in medicine and
science grew as a result of it but but
they're not easy subjects to discuss
with an audience especially when you
have so many characters and Twitter and
you're you're trying to get out a
complex idea right and also like you're
not too
there's a lot of Twitter pages that I
follow where people just trying to gross
people out you're actually educating
people about the history and and we all
should be really thankful that these
people went through all the stuff so
that we don't have to yeah absolutely I
always say to my audience so I been
going around the world sort of
demolishing romantic notions about
people why you might think about what
it's like to live in the past because it
was pretty pretty bad and I I have
visuals as well and I've had four men
faint so far it's always been man it's
just a commentary right now it's
ancestors of the bitch those weaklings
coming to my lecture and I think what it
is though is people think I'm gonna see
something gross so I'm not gonna eat and
then their blood sugar plummets so it's
not really the closest but they're not
really prepared you know and there's
interest yeah and they're standing
sometimes I I give lectures at this
incredible museum called the old
operating theatre in London it's the
second oldest in the world and so you
have to stand because it's like a
Victorian operating theatre and so
people lock their knees or whatever oh
wow so you give actual lectures in the
real theaters where they used to cut
yeah yeah I did my book launch there and
if people want to see it I filmed sort
of a like a theatrical scene of a young
lister attending an operation in that
theatre and it's on my youtube channel
called under the knife and I really want
to get this made into a movie I'm trying
to come into Hollywood and convince
Hollywood that this Quaker surgeon from
the Victorian period deserves this
cinema
feature but it is an epic story he saved
more lives than any other person to ever
live look it is an epic story and for
anybody who's ever gone through
operations and I've gone through several
of them we owe those people a massive
debt yeah you don't have to be awake
stretch to the jail at both my knees
reconstructed wake up and they're fixed
yeah it's amazing and in the past before
anesthesia a lot of times patients were
sat in chairs so they weren't laid down
and they were sat in these very high
chairs so that their feet dangled so
they couldn't brace against the knife if
you think about pushing off of course on
there's a there's a
worry about a guy named Robert Penman
and I know we have images and I'm sure
YouTube won't take those down he he
comes to a Robert Liston the fastest
knife in the West End in the eighth in
1828 and he has this huge facial tumour
growing I mean it's been growing for
about eight years it's taking up his
whole face he can't breathe now and
Liston looks at him and says I can't do
this operation which is tantamount to a
death sentence but he goes up to
Scotland and he goes there he is
Wow yeah it's it's incredible when you
see that painting on so Penman goes up
to Scotland and he sees a guy named
James Simon's I'm agrees to do this
operation and pemon is sat for 24
minutes in a chair restrained while this
thing is caught out of his face first in
a bucket and and survived yeah well we
have a picture of him later in life Wow
you know and he's doing kind of like an
ugly Abraham Lincoln and Lincoln wasn't
really known for his looks like that he
doesn't have that thing on his face
though yeah see that the jaw is
definitely slimmer but he doesn't look
too deform considering what he went
through so it is incredible um you get
such crazy stories like there's a woman
who has a mastectomy in 1840 without any
anesthetic now at this time you would
have if you were wealthy or if you're
middle-class you'd have this operation
in your home you just have it unlike
your kitchen table which is which would
have been safer than going into the
hospitals really yeah because the
hospitals were crawling with all kinds
of infection so hospitals were places
for the poor and to give you an idea of
how gross it was the bug catcher who had
rid on the beds of lice he was paid more
than the doctors and Surgeons in this
time yeah because I mean that's pretty
important right there's maggots all
kinds of things crawling around in these
hospitals so if you were wealthy or
middle-class you had your surgeon come
to your home and so she has a surgeon
come and the surgeon determines that yes
the breast has to come off and says I'm
gonna return but I'm not gonna tell you
the day which would make me more anxious
he thought it was gonna help her not
focus on it but all you would be
thinking about right is when is this guy
vision that's hot that's a person
without breasts yeah
it was like I'll just show up it'll be
easy and so he shows up and he goes into
her bedroom and he opens his hand and
shows that the knife he's gonna use and
he says to prepare her soul for death
but this isn't very confidence inspired
any doctors listening don't tell your
patients to prepare their soul for death
and and she does survive and she talks
about how it's so vascular that the
blood blinds him at one point and so
what do you think I can't get worse he
can't see and he's under on she is under
his hand for an hour and a half oh my
god away and she survives she ends up
living a long and somewhat happy life
I'm sure she had a lot of nightmares
yeah there we see so do they tie this
woman down like how did they oh yeah
they would have definitely had to
restrain her I mean oh people were
probably a little bit stronger or more
able to adapt to pain than we are but
nonetheless there would have been some
pretty heavy what year was this that was
in the 1840s do we know when cancer
became common or was it always common in
humans yeah that's that's a good
question the oldest archaeological
record I believe is 2,000 years old of
metastatic cancers so it's older than
you think they're diagnosing it for for
centuries and centuries I'm not really
an expert in history of cancer but it is
around and so with breast cancer you
know probably by the time it got to the
stage of mastectomy it probably would
have spread if you think about like you
know it being visible to the naked eye
but yet she survived she did survive and
so then you have to question whether she
had breast cancer or maybe it was some
kind of like yeah maybe a cyst and she
went through that for that yeah and
again before antiseptics before Lister
comes on on and comes up with germ
fighting techniques this would have been
so dangerous because you have this open
cavity in windows and so Joseph Lister
when he comes up with his antiseptic
techniques he actually performs a
mastectomy on his sister on his dining
room table Oh which and she survives and
that's in the book see this this would
be a great movie don't you think yeah I
do think it would be a great movie
it's like it would be a great movie for
the Coen brothers yeah you know because
it's so chaos Ville you know and all
that kind of readiness yeah I do good
period pieces too yeah cuz they could
make it more entertaining that world but
this guy with the face where they cut
that tumor out of it say so for twenty
four minutes that's all it took to cut
that thing out of his face in that that
case yeah and remember a course it
depended on the skill of your surgeon so
he goes to a very good surgeon named
James Syme but there are there's a story
so going back to penises there's
lithotomy is the removal of the stone
which you saw kind of a demonstration
there um and it was incredibly painful
so if they stuck a rod on the penis and
they caught through the scrotum they
removed the stone and of course there
was no pain medication and it was just
awful did they drink you know it's kind
of a myth because of course drinking
within your blood hmm but someone asked
me they said I heard that surgeons would
punch the patient out and I was like
well you'd be really good to knock
someone out on a first punch and of
course he'd do more damage you could do
a lot of damage to the head that's
definitely didn't happen unless someone
can prove me wrong maybe there's like a
weird example but I've never come across
that um so so it was kind of it was you
and the surgeon and with the lithotomy
it takes about a good surgeon it took
about five minutes well there's a guy
named Steven Pollard in 1828 who goes in
to have this done now it's incredibly
embarrassing it's you're you know you're
naked from the waist down it's an
embarrassing operation it's painful he's
brought into the theater and the surgeon
ends up taking over an hour because he's
so intact and the patient is screaming
you know please just stop just stop
and um and the surgeon yells back at him
for having an abnormal Anatomy which how
would you like that you're sitting there
on the on the table and you're being
blamed for this going wrong and he pulls
through the operation but he does die a
post-operative infection abnormal
Anatomy how so he just said you have
abnormal Anatomy and so on the autopsy
report it was revealed that there was
nothing abnormal about his Anatomy the
surgeon just was really announced
Oh God yeah it wasn't blaming the guy
did you have lunch before this yeah I
did but I'm all right good that's well
that's good because then you won't faint
well I hosted fear factor I've seen
everything yes nothing what's worse I
mean was there ever a segment on fear
factor that you thought I don't know if
I can watch that
no no I'd uh when they had a drink come
that was rough show canceled yeah that
was the second version of Fear Factor
when it came back for a brief period of
time and they were going way too hard
they were trying to do them so we're
there yeah yeah they're like fear
factors back and it's crazier than ever
and they just went way over the top
that's what they do with TV right yeah
always pushing the boundaries they
didn't have to yeah because it's just
gone with regular Fear Factor and we
would have all been fine we could do
historical Fear Factor create these sort
of horrible things it was a blessing in
disguise but